[Music]
this
is dicing with death we want to be safe
and in search of safety the countries of
the world in the face of
covid close down much of the economy yet
a lancet
study confirmed that global deaths from
alcohol are 2.8 million annually
three times the current number of deaths
caused by covid if we wanted to be safe
and save lives all we'd have to do is
stop drinking is the reality
that we pretend to want to be safe
when someone else is responsible but
when we're left to our own devices and
desires
we frequently choose risk instead
or do we want safety but we just don't
realize that routine activities are
dangerous to help us explore
some of these themes we're joined by
trinitra gupta
professor of theoretical epidemiology at
oxford university
who recently made headlines with our
outspoken comments
against the widespread acceptance of
imperial college's
model of coronavirus deaths david d
friedman
is one of the most renowned
anarcho-capitalist
theorists in the world his book the
machinery of freedom
defends the idea that we should set
capitalism
free completely and indira jason
is a human rights lawyer and legal
activist she regularly argues in the
indian supreme court
and she's one of the most successful
defenders of women's rights
and environmental standards in the world
so to begin our debate our discussion
i'm going to ask
each member of our panel to set out
their stall they'll get three minutes
to make their pitch in answer to this
question
if we care about safety why do we
continually engage
in risky behavior i'm going to ask
indira
to start us off you ask
why do we indulge in risky behavior
although we care about our safety
in my opinion this question is not about
me
whether i indulge in risky behavior
i think it's a question which is
addressed to collective risky behavior
as reflected in the civilizational
choices we have made
as countries as nations and globally
as the family of nations it's that
behavior which is risky so
my counter question with me would be
do i have a choice about uh
the behavior that i indulge in or is my
behavior conditioned by the external
circumstances
which are a given which are political
choices
which are choices which our leaders make
and uh um let me just come directly to
the question of corbit19
we all know that this is with the caveat
i'm not a scientist as you rightly point
out as a human rights activist
but and we all know we've read enough to
know
that kovit19 is is a respiratory disease
we get it from the air now i want to ask
everyone a question do we have any
control over the quality of the air we
breathe
i i have none i can't go around my
day-to-day life wearing a mask or
using oxygen i want to lead a free life
i want to re lead a life where
i'm sure that the air which i breed is
as clean as it possibly could be now
the path of development that we have
chosen the world over does not permit
this
to happen and therefore i would contest
your proposition
that i indulge in risky behavior
i care about my safety but as a
civilization we don't care about other
people's
safety safety is indivisible
isn't it i can't remain safe while you
are not safe
and so uh how do we make sure
that the world we live in is space safe
uh in today's world we all know uh
that what global warming has done and
what it means
we don't seem to think
intergenerationally we think
we seem to think only for today we don't
seem to understand
the damage that we have caused uh to
generations who are going to come
after us that's one of our problems when
we talk about
a risky behavior and uh
you see we need to question whether
wearing masks social distancing and
sanitization are the answers
uh to the to the imminent risk of death
that we face
uh in my opinion they are not in my
opinion
uh we need to know we need to decide
whether
the so-called normal is not there is not
the circumstance which brought us to
this story pass
and whether we want to question that
normal
not a return uh to that normal
uh because the return to that normal
bridge bring us back
uh today we have sars we have kobe 2 who
knows when we'll have kobe 3 who knows
when we'll have kobe 4.
to the best of my knowledge and we have
an epidemiologist with us to guide us
through this discussion
i i know that scientists over the world
had warned us
of of possible pandemics and i'm not
talking about science fiction
i'm talking about hard data we know
that these virus cross uh
species uh we know that they
they can they can jump from say bats
or monkeys to human beings now the
question is
did we ever think how we could address
these issues we never did
and a part of it i'm just going to stop
you there india you got us off to a
fantastic start
thank you but you have had your three
minutes
so i'm going to move now to david i'm
going to ask you the same question
if we care about safety why do we
continually engage
in risky behavior because we care about
a lot of other things as well
you put the alternatives incorrectly
everybody takes risks
including indira i expect there are
occasions when she
drives in a car and doesn't have to and
when you drive in a car
especially in some cities she may have
been in
there is a risk that somebody will run
into you
she presumably goes outside where she
could be hit by lightning
when she doesn't have to that in the
real world we do not have the
alternative of living a
life with zero risk that isn't an
alternative it never has been
we happen to live in about the safest
world that has ever existed so far
because of
the benefits of modern medicine and
high real incomes by historical
standards and all the rest of it
uh but nonetheless we have trade-offs
and we have we always have trade-offs in
everything it's
all very well to say your life is
infinitely valuable but nobody
acts that way nobody is willing to give
up
everything else he cares about in order
to live a day longer that's not how
people behave it's not how rational
people should behave
so i think the real question is always
one of treatments
it's always how much that would it cost
how much would you have to give up
in order to reduce the risk by some
amount is it worth doing
and if i imagine the consequences of a
lockdown
i imagine somebody who spent 10 years
creating a small business a local
restaurant
that's where his heart is that's what
he's given his life to
if you could tell him you can save your
restaurant
at the cost of one percent chance of
dying i think most people would take
that risk
50 they probably wouldn't 100 they
should
surely wouldn't so it seems to me that
in the real world
there are always trade-offs and we are
always willing to accept
some increase in risk in order to avoid
giving up other things that are really
important to us and
you know the very extreme case is the
person who's willing to give up his life
for something he really cares about
and he's willing to do that because what
he wants to get doesn't depend on his
being alive
the reason we think of life is
infinitely valuable
is because most of us would say we would
i wouldn't sell my heart
deliverable today for any price at all
but the reason is not your life is
infinitely valuable it's that dollars
are worthless to a corpse
so the payment would be would be
worthless but as i say there are people
who are willing to sell their lives
uh martyrs of one sort or another a
world war one soldier charging into
machine gun fire you can
make up your you know imagine whichever
story you like but there certainly have
been such people in the past
and that's because they are seeking
something that doesn't require them to
be alive to collect
from most of us that's not the case and
so most of us are not willing to
sell our heart for immediate delivery
whatever the price we're offering
so anyway i think that the basic answer
is that it is perfectly entirely
rational people of course make mistakes
but it is rational to accept some risks
when the cost of preventing them is too
high
thank you very much david um so trinitra
if we care about safety why do we inca
why do we continually engage
in risky behavior well first of all let
me apologize for
underestimating the risk that my
landline which never rings
would ring at this point um okay so i
mean
some of what i'm going to say obviously
will reiterate what's just been said
so but perhaps the the slight difference
in focus
might be that i'd like to
draw attention not just to risk and
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest
ideas